this is the question I got asked okay
and some people are scratching their
heads over which is fair enough because
it doesn't quite match up with the
question even sorry the limits that I
showed you before okay the ones were
thinking off that we proved on
excellence sine X X on tan X and their
reciprocals be sure they're approaching
one no problems okay
now this guy kind of defies that because
well you don't you definitely don't have
tans and you don't we have signs but
you've got an identity happening down
there which is going to eliminate your
son right so the question is if it's not
gonna be one of these enemies which one
should we use so first let's see we can
do with this now what - science man when
you see that what's the first thing your
brain does Qwest quick good so you've
got the limit as theta approaches 0 or
theta squared on square okay all right
now the first thing I'm gonna say after
that is that if I'm gonna spread and
talk the square of bottom I can consider
the fraction and then I want to consider
that as a squid so if I can work out
what that's doing right then I'll work
out what's the whole thing no theta as
that approaches zero as theater bridge 0
theta become zero
that's okay it's just theater on the top
now what's happening a because they
don't hold on we know what happens -
cause they don't there's cos theta
right now the reason why I've drawn it
positive so that you can see whether you
approach it from this side which by the
way is written like this theta
approaches zero from the positive side
or whether you approach it from this
side which is the limit as Peter
approaches 0 of the from the negative
side you're like it's negative zero when
there are limits there are what's
happening well they both approaching the
same out of you namely one right so
therefore if I can actually evaluate
this limit having closed either on the
denominator it's not a problem for me ok
so this is zero
one squared which I hope is zero which
in my arithmetic I think okay so even
though it doesn't fit into one of these
it ought to be a limit we can evaluate
remember if I can get it into a shape
where I can simply actually substitute
feet of in then it's fine now just to
give you an example of where this is a
similar kind of things happens do you
remember when we were differentiating
the square root of x remember doing this
one from first principles vaguely
ringabel
okay now okay what you're gonna get is
the limit as H approaches zero of this
guy okay now the solution to this
doesn't actually completely cancel out
the denominator you still get something
on the bottom but the point is that what
you end up getting you can actually
evaluate at H equals zero just like you
can value this at theory to zero okay so
in terms of evaluating minutes you've
got these kinds of strategies get it
into some kind of limit that I recognize
which I had to prove but now I know they
both approach one okay or alternatively
just get into some kind of shape using
identities that you nerd so you can just
stick in theory kazoo and it will work
out Zenoss you question you get lots of
those kinds of variations the reason
being that there's only so many
questions you can write using those
identities and math teachers get bored
so okay